reisefreiheit aber in etappen für die
eu-länder wird die deutsche reisewarnung
bald fallen
doch für den rest der welt gilt sie erst
einmal weiter energiekonzept für die
zukunft die bundesregierung will
deutschland beim wasserstoff zur nummer
eins machen in der welt und ende der
ermittlungen im mordfall palme schwedens
staatsanwälte sagen der mörder des
ex-regierungschefs ist tot
die nachrichten nicht erst heute mit
christian sievert in hallen und danke
dass sie dabei sind heute bei uns
christian ist auch dabei für den sport
nachher voller freude der hallo und
guten abend eine gute und eine schlechte
nachricht für alle sommerurlauber heute
zuerst die gute innerhalb von europa
soll reisen wieder möglich sein
jetzt die schlechte alle anderen länder
bleiben nach ansicht der bundesregierung
tabu und zwar bis ende des sommers
gucken wir uns mal die details an
klar ist für 31 europäische länder wird
die reisewarnung aufgehoben für die
meisten schon ab kommenden montag und
die grenzkontrollen fallen weg für alle
anderen länder gilt die reisewarnung bis
ende august weiter das trifft auch
traditionelle urlaubsländer der
deutschen wie die türkei ägypten oder
tunesien
allerdings sollen die warnungen im
einzelfall immer wieder geprüft werden
david guetta hat berichtet noch
kontrollieren sie hier am übergang nach
österreich im bayerischen kiefersfelden
seit drei monaten sind schlagbäume und
grenzpolizisten zurück maßnahmen die
laut innenminister notwendig gewesen
sein um das corona virus zu bekämpfen
und nun auslaufen zum 15 juni ist
schluss damit ist wieder innerhalb
europas der europäischen union muss man
genauer sagen die freizügigkeit
hergestellt auch die quarantäne regeln
für reisende aus der eu sollen
schrittweise wegfallen ausnahme noch
schweben wegen hoher infektionszahlen
das ende der grenzkontrollen wird in der
opposition höchst unterschiedlich
bewertet
wir sagen grenzkontrollen tun der
inneren sicherheit deutschland sehr gut
das kann und sollte weiter durchgeführt
und durchgesetzt werden
diese maßnahme ist richtig aber sie
kommen zu spät schon seit einigen wochen
lässt das infektionsgeschehen eine
öffnung der binnengrenzen zu
gleichzeitig wurden für mehr als 160
nicht-eu-länder die reisewarnung
verlängert bis ende august zwar sollen
regelmäßig lockerungen überprüft werden
doch unsicherheit bleibt etwa für
hunderttausende potentielle türkei oder
ägypten urlaub
eine reisewarnung ist kein reiseverbot
die entscheidung ist letztlich eine
vereine die in der verantwortung des
einzelnen liegt wenn gefahr für leib und
leben truhe wird eine solche
reisewarnung ausgesprochen
stornierungswünschen sinken die
hemmschwelle zu reisen steigt wenn ich
die eu-staaten freigeben muss ich sagen
es gilt auch für alle anderen staaten
einschließlich der türkei die nicht mehr
infizierte haben als die eu-staaten für
eu urlauber klaren die aussichten
langsam auf wien darüber hinaus aber das
fernweh plagt der muss sich wohl noch
etwas gedulden
und da die frage nach ist da wohl an
unseren korrespondenten jörg brase jörg
wie reagiert die türkei also von
regierungsseite gibt es dann auch keine
reaktion einige türkische
tourismusverbände die haben sich
enttäuscht geäußert haben gesagt die
infektionszahlen liegen jedoch viel
niedriger als in italien oder spanien
außerdem habe die tourismusindustrie
hätten die hotels habe
sicherheitsmaßnahmen ergriffen dass die
pionierarbeit geleistet worden und nun
hofft man auf eine ausnahmegenehmigung
für die türkei man hört das auf
regierungsebene da auch durchaus schon
gespräche geführt werden und heute nacht
zu hören wir auch sowohl die quarantäne
pflicht in der türkei fallen ab morgen
wollen einige fluglinien auch wieder
ziele in deutschland anfliegen das heißt
man hofft in der türkei nach wie vor
dass es vielleicht anfang juli zu beginn
der deutschen ferien sommerferien an
doch möglich sein könnte wie der urlaub
in der türkei zu machen aus istanbul
jörg brase dankeschön und damit zu
unserem nächsten thema heute abend
wasserstoff das ist für viele experten
der klimafreundliche energieträger der
zukunft denn kohle öl erdgas alle
fossilen energien belasten das klima
wasserstoff nicht
deutschland legt jetzt ein gewaltiges
programm auf um neue technologien rund
um wasserstoff anzuschieben
das schauen wir uns gleich genauer an
erst hat anselm stern die wichtigsten
fakten
riesenflieger riesenschiffe riesen
fabriken klimafreundlich betrieben mit
wasserstoff oder mehr autos die
wasserstoff tanken große ziele
das problem man braucht gewaltige mengen
wasserstoff der entsteht durch
elektrolyse also durch das aufspalten
von wasser in wasserstoff und sauerstoff
für dieses verfahren aber wird enorm
viel strom benötigt kommt der aus
erneuerbaren energien spricht man vom
grünen wasserstoff die beste lösung für
das klima aber oft wird wasserstoff auch
durch fossile energie gewonnen also etwa
mit strom aus kohlekraftwerken das ist
dann der graue wasserstoff produziert
man davon eine tonne werden etwa zehn
tonnen co2 ausgestoßen das wäre fürs
klima dann ziemlich schlecht sind also
noch einige wichtige fragen zu klären
bevor die wasserstoff revolution kommen
kann
deutschland will sich weltweit in der
spitze etablieren den forschung und
produktion
wie das gelingen soll berichtet heiko
ramms
flüssiges glühendes metall der
energiebedarf von stahlwerken wie bei
thyssenkrupp in duisburg ist enorm die
klimabilanz entsprechend schlecht jetzt
will das unternehmen in zukunft mit
grünem wasserstoff um steuern
wir wollen hier mit einem
gemeinschaftsprojekt mit der rwe schon
im jahr 2022 einen unserer hochöfen mit
wasserstoff beschicken dadurch können
wir kohle reduzieren und insofern
erheblich an co2 einsparen grüner
wasserstoff als zukunftstechnologie
darauf setzt auch die bundesregierung
mit ihrer nationalen wasserstoff
strategie setzt sie sich hohe ziele wir
wollen die nummer eins werden auch aus
gründen in unserer wettbewerbsfähigkeit
aber vor allen dingen würde wollen dass
unsere ehrgeizigen klimaschutzziele
erreicht werden um große mengen
wasserstoff produzieren zu können sieht
die wasserstoff strategie der
bundesregierung vor in einem ersten
schritt bis 2030 erzeugungsanlagen für
wasserstoff von bis zu fünf gigawatt
gesamtleistung aufzubauen
bis 2040 sollen es zehn gigawatt sein
dies entspreche der leistung von zehn
atomkraftwerken
deutschland will mit anderen ländern
zusammenarbeiten etwa mit marokko
entwicklungsminister müller
unterzeichnet mit der botschafterin
marokkos einen vertrag über eine
pilotanlage ohne die sonne afrikas
werden wir diese ziele nicht
verwirklichen können wir setzen auf die
weiterentwicklung in der zusammenarbeit
mit den entwicklungsländern wasserstoff
weiterzuentwickeln und hier entscheidet
sich das weltklima 9 milliarden euro
will die bundesregierung gegen die
umsetzung der wasserstoff strategie
investieren das ist auch nötig denn noch
ist die produktion von wasserstoff sehr
teuer
weitere fragen und vor allem antworten
rund um den wasserstoff haben wir online
für sie in der zdf- heute- app unter
anderem wo die fallstricke liegen und
wie es japan geschafft hat zum vorreiter
beim wasserstoff zu werden noch ein
beschluss des kabinetts heute
deutschland will wieder flüchtlinge in
not aufnehmen so sollen laut
innenminister horst seehofer
350 bis 500 minderjährige migranten aus
griechenland einreisen dürfen
die meisten von ihnen seien kranke
kinder aus flüchtlingslagern auf den
griechischen inseln
außerdem habe deutschland italien und
malta angeboten aus seenot gerettet
migranten zu übernehmen
mehr als 100 tage nach der
bürgerschaftswahl in hamburg haben spd
und grüne die fortsetzung ihrer
regierungsarbeit besiegelt wegen der
korona krise war der koalitionsvertrag
erst in den vergangenen wochen
ausgehandelt wurden amtsinhaber peter
tschentscher von der spd wurde heute zum
ersten bürgermeister gewählt und wir
schauen jetzt auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen in deutschland gibt es weiterhin
wenig neue infektionen ihre zahl ist
aber leicht gestiegen
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 380 menschen neu
angesteckt deutschland und auch das
übrige europa erscheinen das virus also
im griff zu haben derzeit ganz anders
sieht es weltweit aus die
weltgesundheitsorganisation meldet die
höchsten zahlen von neuinfektionen seit
beginn der pandemie vor allem wegen der
situation in südasien und in südamerika
in brasilien allein gestern 32.000
neuansteckungen oder peru nur ein gutes
drittel der einwohnerzahl von
deutschland aber schon jetzt mehr
infizierte tendenz steigend in asien
liegt indien mit fast 280.000
infizierten inzwischen auf dem fünften
platz der weltweit am stärksten
betroffenen länder
auch im nachbarland pakistan geht die
kurve steil nach oben und dann afrika wo
kaum getestet wird allerdings steigt in
südafrika die zahl der neuinfektionen
sprunghaft an
in den letzten 7 tagen um 50% sandra
teils höchstpersönlich öffnete
südafrikas präsident rambos sei die tür
zum hospital of hope dem krankenhaus der
hoffnung das kongresszentrum in kapstadt
ist jetzt ein lazarett mit 850 betten
weil die krankenhäuser die flut an
patienten kaum noch schaffen
die bei touristen so beliebte provinz
westkap ist das epizentrum der pandemie
zwei drittel der infektionen wurden hier
nachgewiesen sowie 77 prozent der korona
toten
die regierung plant weitere lazarette
ich will mehr betten sehen die hier
installiert werden so dass wir vor der
kurve sind so dass man uns nicht mit
heruntergelassenen hosen finde wir
müssen in der lage sein das virus zu
bekämpfen wir sind im krieg
doch um die waffen ist es teilweise
schlecht bestellt viele
krankenschwestern und ärzte haben sich
angesteckt und fallen aus allein im
tiger burg krankenhaus in kapstadt sind
das rund 300 mindestens vier starben
experten gehen davon aus dass die lage
in anderen städten bald ähnlich sein
könnte
es gibt bereits zeichen dafür dass die
zahlen in johannesburg in der provinz
gauteng hochgehen
meine prognose ist dass wir vor allem in
den metropolen sehen werden dass leider
andere gebiete in südafrika kapstadt
folgen werden vor allem in den townships
wo zu viele menschen auf engstem raum
leben breitet sich das virus schnell aus
und der staat hat dem kaum etwas
entgegenzusetzen
in europa hatte es norditalien ja
besonders getroffen die bilder aus
bergamo schockierten die ganze welt hier
stellen sich jetzt drängende fragen die
menschen wollen wissen warum ist das
gesundheitssystem unter der last der
korona pandemie zusammengebrochen
angehörige von corona opfern haben rund
50 strafanzeigen eingereicht wir
prangern an steht auf ihren masken vor
dem gericht in bergamo
mein vater starb am 16 märz er hatte 15
tage husten und fieber und niemand kam
wir wollen herausfinden wer
hauptsächlich verantwortlich ist die
staatsanwaltschaft soll jetzt klären
warum bergamo nicht früher unter
quarantäne gestellt wurde
obwohl das viele gefordert hatten
nächstes thema israels regierung will
einen teil des palästinensischen
westjordanlandes annektieren also die
volle staatliche kontrolle übernehmen
sie fühlt sich dabei vom amerikanischen
präsidenten unterstützt auch wenn das
gegen internationales recht wäre
darauf hat heute der deutsche
außenminister hingewiesen heiko maas ist
in israel zu besuch und er kritisiert
die pläne auf eine drohung mit
konsequenzen allerdings verzichtet er
nicola albrecht beobachtet in besuch
corona gruß zwischen bundesaußenminister
maß und seinem neuen israelischen
amtskollegen ashkenasi in jerusalem
sie geben sich bemüht locker betonen die
deutsch israelische freundschaft beim
heiklen thema israels an aktionspläne
setzt maß auf sanfte diplomatie
gemeinsam mit der europäischen union
sind wir der ansicht dass eine infektion
nicht mit internationalem recht
vereinbar wäre jetzt ist die zeit der
diplomatie und des dialogs der
israelische außenminister zeigt sich
unbeeindruckt erreicht den ball weiter
an die palästinenser wir erwarten von
der internationalen gemeinschaft dass
sie den palästinensern klar macht wenn
sie sich des dialogs verweigern wird das
den palästinensischen interessen nicht
dienen
hier im jordantal nur einem der
möglichen gebiete die annektiert werden
könnten leben rund 60.000 palästinenser
unter israelischer besatzung einer von
ihnen ist hasan mohammad er persönlich
habe bislang keine probleme mit den
jüdischen siedlern sie geben ihm arbeit
erklärt er uns doch eine annexion mache
ihm angst ich will unter
palästinensischer souveränität leben
was soll aus uns werden wenn annektiert
wird welchen status sollen wir haben
naja maß trifft sich nicht persönlich
mit der palästinensischen führung
quarantänevorschriften israels die
begründung das gespräch mit premier
netanjahu findet ohne presse statt
heiko maas mission der israelischen
regierung die annexion den völkerrechts
bruch auszureden hat auf israelischer
seite wohl wenig wirkungskraft hier weiß
man nur zu gut dass aus deutschland oder
der eu kaum konsequenzen zu erwarten
sind
geplant ist die annexion für den ersten
juli genau der tag an dem deutschland
die eu ratspräsidentschaft und den
vorsitz im un-sicherheitsrat übernimmt
zwei schüsse auf offener straße mitten
in stockholm am ende ist der
regierungschef tod und für schweden
beginnt eine jahrzehntelange suche nach
dem mörder die viele schweden an ihren
ermittlungsbehörden zweifeln lässt mit
mysteriösen zu fällen und falschen
verdächtigen jetzt ein paukenschlag im
mordfall olof palme der
ministerpräsident galt als
ausnahmetalent der sozialdemokratie
wurde von vielen bewundert von manchen
verachtet seit dem 28
februar 1986 kursieren viele
spekulationen
jetzt sagt die staatsanwaltschaft wir
wissen wer der mörder ist mehr von
hannah hebestreit stieg engström hat
nach meinung der ermittler 1986 den
damaligen schwedischen
ministerpräsidenten olof palme
erschossen
zu dem schluss kommen die neuen
ermittler nachdem sie drei jahre lang
die alten akten durchforstet hatten ohne
neue belege zu präsentieren haben sie
engstellen zum täter erklärt und er ist
seit vielen jahren täter- und deshalb
habe ich entschieden
diese untersuchung nicht weiter
fortzusetzen engström war schon einmal
ins visier der ermittler geraten weil er
zur tatzeit vor ort war und weil er ein
mögliches motiv hatte hass auf palme der
schweden zu einem multikulturellen land
erklärt die gleichberechtigung forciert
und abrüstung gefordert hatte
für stockholm journalisten ist es
skandalös dass die ermittler seiner spur
damals nicht gefolgt war
mit hilfe des fbi hatte man schon in den
90er jahren ein täterprofil erstellt das
genau auf ihn passte aber es hat so
lange gedauert
die polizei konnte das ist alles einfach
nicht klären
in alle möglichen richtungen liefen die
ermittlungen militante kurden wurden
ebenso verdächtigt wie das
apartheid-regime südafrikas die heutigen
entscheidungen haben es die ermittler
nicht geschafft das schwedische trauma
zu heilen
ich weiß nicht recht was ich sagen soll
ich bin enttäuscht hatte ich mir mehr
versprochen
es hat die ganze zeit keine beweise
gegeben jetzt soll wohl der mord erklärt
und abgeschlossen ohne dass ein prozess
nicht in das dunkel mögliche
hintermänner bringen kann bleibt der
mordfall palme ein mysterium
ein ende heute oder vielleicht doch kein
ende wir werden sehen
das waren wir sport jetzt mit kristin
otto ohne happy end für die kleinen denn
bayer leverkusen steht als erste
mannschaft im finale des dfb
pokalwettbewerbs durch den klaren 3
0-erfolg des favorisierten
bundesligisten endete auch der traum des
ersten fc saarbrücken als erster
viertliga vereines endspiel zu erreichen
friedlich ist brücken hatte sich viel
vorgenommen doch in diesen pokal
halbfinale waren die rollen klar
verteilt da half auch das hoffen der
fans nicht die mit abstand in der
innenstadt daumen drücken
wir haben uns von anfang an was anderes
vorgenommen haben das nicht richtig
umgesetzt
das macht mich sauer nach 94 tagen
locker und ohne spielpraxis begann
saarbrücken zu vorsichtig schon in der
11 minute dann der treffer von diaby
mitten in saarbrücker herz und acht
minuten später mit dem 2 0 durch mario
wurde klar eine weitere pokalsensation
wird es nicht geben das 13 0 durch
bellarabi besiegelte das aus haben uns
dann achtbar aus der affäre gezogen
haben uns nicht abschlachten lassen aber
unterm strich überwiegt die enttäuschung
die leverkusener stehen zum vierten mal
im dfb-pokalfinale
ihr einziger sieg gelang ihnen 1993 und
leverkusens gegner am 4 juli in berlin
wird nachher zwischen titelverteidiger
bayern münchen und eintracht frankfurt
ermittelt bei den frauen steht die
finalpaarung bereits fest wolfsburg
trifft auf essen wie sgs gewannen das
zweite halbfinale in leverkusen mit 3 zu
1 zuvor hatten die titelverteidigerinnen
aus wolfsburg bei arminia bielefeld
souverän mit 5 0 triumphiert nach zwei
treffern von claudia nitsche markierte
saragossas die tor den schlusspunkt
wolfsburg nun mit der chance auf den
sechsten pokalgewinn nacheinander
ja so viel von mir naja christlichen
große geburtstagsparty sind in zeiten
von corona ja bekanntlich passé unser
heutiger jubilar sieht das eher gelassen
prinz philip der ehemann von königin
elizabeth der zweite wird heute 99 das
ist ein offizielles geburtstags foto und
er sieht aus wie immer der prinz feiert
heute auf schloss windsor seit drei
jahren hat er sich weitgehend aus der
öffentlichkeit zurückgezogen
heute an seinem großen tag genießt er
vor allem die ruhe und so heißt es aus
palastkreisen mit seiner ehefrau das
gemeinsame leichte mittag ersten
herzlichen glückwunsch auch an alle die
jetzt jubeln können hier sind die
lottozahlen und sie lauten 2 11 17 20 36
42 superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de und dem zdf text auf seite
55 7
morgen gibt es schauer gewitter und
etwas sonne da scheint also von allem
was dabei zu sein mehr gleich von
präsident ali beim wetter um 23.15 gibt
es das heute journal mit dem kollegen
claus kleber er hat fragen an den
bundesaußenminister zu dessen
israel-politik verborgen freut sich hier
petra gerster auf sie ich sage danke für
das interesse und im namen des gesamten
teams machen sie sich ein angenehm haben
[Musik]
ein schulamt und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter tiefer luftdruck sie immer noch
vorherrschend über süddeutschland hier
dieses tief über norditalien lenkt immer
noch feuchte luftmassen in den süden und
so gibt es weiteren regen ja und dieses
tief bei den britischen inseln rauscht
runter richtung iberische halbinsel und
wird sich dort in den nächsten tagen
einnisten
schauen wir in die nacht und da gibt es
schauer im norden die wandern allmählich
nach nordwesten
im süden da ist es weiterhin ziemlich
dicht bewölkt mit kräftigem regen
temperaturen sinken dazu auf 14 grad in
schleswig holstein und 8 grad am
alpenrand
morgen dann weitere schauer und gewitter
bevorzugt über dem bergland teilweise
gibt es auch trockene abschnitte zb im
südosten aber im norden ziemlich dichte
bewölkung und hier regnet es immer
wieder mal bei temperaturen von bis zu
24 grad nach osten hin und 17 grad vor
allem an der ostsee dort ist es am
kühlsten die nächsten tage am freitag
wird es erste gewitter geben im bergland
bis 30 grad heiß ja und dann geht es zur
sache
es gibt heftige schauer und gewitter am
samstag dazu bis 31 grad und auch in der
nacht auf den sonntag gewitter sowie am
sonntag selbst damit ein schöner amt